on retrouve sébastien martin biron paul
journet pour le panel bonsoir à vous
trois bonsoir bonsoir
alors on a on a vu sebastian en parlant
tout début d'émission monsieur monsieur
legault qui déchire il
on va l'écouter encore ceux qui
n'étaient pas avec nous en tout début
sur la réouverture des restaurants des
lieux publics on écoute on revient j'ai
été en affaire donc chèque c'est
important la prévisibilité puis quand je
vous disais je disais mille
propriétaires de restaurants qui ne
disent pas ce que je me prépare pour le
29 a commencé à acheter la marchandise
tout est aujourd'hui le regarde le
nombre de cols et chansons fait mais on
se donne jusqu'au début de la semaine
prochaine pour leur dire ce qui va
arriver à partir du 29 octobre
alors martin se lance avec vous on sent
vraiment qu'on est déchiré à québec la
claque est de la question des
restaurants des cégeps des universités
ça commence à il ya un doute qui
s'installe
c'est sûr qu'on est sur un plateau le
plateau et au la bonne nouvelle
s'explique c'est qu'on est quand même à
1000 par jour alors ça monte pas mais
quand même c'est c'est assez haut
cela dit les choses changent btan à
québec les décisions évolué et pour les
pour ce qui des restaurants a notamment
des quelques appels que j'ai pu faire en
fin de journée je comprends que le
gouvernement voudrait faire quelque
chose et trouver une solution qui
pourrait s'étendre dans le temps est ce
que les prochains jours ça va baisser un
peu si c'est le cas ça va permettre ça
va ouvrir la voie mais l'idée c'est de
cesser de jouer au yoyo c'est à dire que
il ya une éclosion il avait remonté ont
fermé restreint il ya une accalmie on
les ouvre la deuxième vague arrive on
les ferme et la troisième vague ça c'est
invivable et monsieur legault a dit le
mot pendant son point de presse
aujourd'hui c'est prévisibilité
alors quel type de scénario et
d'arrangements il pourrait y avoir on
travaille ça avec les restaurateurs pour
être capable de trouver une solution qui
va durer dans le temps
ouais paul en ce moment le nombre de cas
n'augmente pas mais de rester dans le
plateau ça ne suffit pas parce que plus
on continue à passer des jours à ce
niveau dans le plateau plus ça va
devenir insoutenable pour le système de
santé
donc il faut carrément que ça commence à
baisser et évidemment le gouvernement
même s'il dit avec raison que les
restaurateurs et les autres
entrepreneurs ont besoin de
prévisibilité vous pouvez pas avoir de
prix de prévisibilité si on sait pas si
le nombre de corps va baisser mais si on
est pessimiste par rapport au nombre de
mois kinois reste à passer à gérer cette
pandémie
ben il va falloir trouver des façons
quel confinement fasse pas trop mal
parce que c'est insoutenable de garder
les restaurants complètement fermée
pendant encore une autre année donc si
on se dit qu'on a encore pour longtemps
on va retrouver des mesures
d'accommodement sauf que le problème qui
je donne juste l'exemple des restaurants
si une démesure d'un comme annoncé de
réduire le nombre de gens de la bulle
par exemple de 6 à 4 de demander aux
gens de garder une distance de 2 m mais
ça fait moins de clients pour les
restaurateurs
donc c'est moins profitable pour eux
certains ne voudront carrément port
ouvrir ou sûr qu'ils vont le faire ils
vont avoir des difficultés à faire leur
donc prévisibilité ce noble intention de
la part de monsieur legault mais c'est
dur est appliquée avec le contexte de
santé publique de pandémie s'est passé
les restaurateurs plaident que il
s'était tellement bien organisé que
c'était peut-être les lieux les plus
sécuritaires de tous les lieux possibles
quand on pense à ce qui a été fermé et
que les gens respectaient bon monsieur
lavoie répondu un peu à ça aujourd'hui
oui mais on s'aperçoit enfin les gens
même s'il y avait des plexiglas pouvait
quand même se rapprocher mais bref ou
yat-il déchirement selon vous la
houssoye conseil des ministres ou même
dans la tête d'hommes et sur le goût de
monsieur dubé oui et déchirements
puisque noter le discours de la dernière
semaine ya une semaine on nous dira
réduisait le plus possible vos contacts
sociaux alors on réduit nos contacts
sociaux mardi à deux jours monsieur
legault ouvre la porte peut-être à des
assouplissements pour les restaurants
les jam les cégeps les universités puis
deux jours plus tard aujourd'hui
tout dans son discours laisse entendre
qu'il y aura pas d'assouplissements donc
il est en effet déchiré entre 7 soutien
à l'économie une partie de l'économie
quand même important ces deux cent mille
employés souffert le secteur de la
restauration au québec il ya une chaîne
alimentaire aussi parce qu'il ya des
producteurs agricoles il ya des
fournisseurs de ces restaurants là qui
eux aussi voient leur chiffre d'affaires
pondre comme neige au soleil donc ils
voudraient ils aimeraient ça mais le fil
conducteur de l'action gouvernementale
en ce moment c'est de réduire la
socialisation les contacte alors on peut
pas rouvrir les restaurants
à moins de preuve contraire on peut pas
ouvrir les restaurants si on veut
réduire nos contacts en tout cas pas les
réduire maintenant pas les réduire tant
que la courbe de baisse - comme paul l'a
dit je veux ajouter quelque chose bien
sûr
déchirement en fait il est aussi sous
pression il y en a parlé et dit j'ai des
amis restaurateurs qui m'appelle chez
plus s'ils sont encore mes amis parce
que les temps sont durs mais le de
déchirements et cette pression là elle
vient de partout les caucus sont
interminables à chaque semaine des
députés reçoivent des appels et les
ministres ou s'ils reçoivent des appels
des maires des préfets des mrc des
restaurateurs des propriétaires de jean
ça n'arrête pas et chacun tire sur son
bout de couverts par exemple moi je suis
limitrophes à nous on orange et et on
essaie le château de cartes il est
difficile à faire tenir pour monsieur
legault en ce moment est d'autant que
gérald ou disais tout à l'heure paul que
dans le milieu des affaires les
l'adhésion n'est absolument plus là si
on compare au moins mars derrière
dernier là il ya des grands doutes qui
s'installent
il ya des organisations qui représentent
des gens d'affaires parce que le
monsieur legault a dit aujourd'hui le
télétravail
allez-y encore plus un télétravail
sortait encore moins dans les gens qui
s'occupent ici parlons de montréal du
centre ville à l'est de vienne foule
mais il faut qu'il faut quoi mais
l'analogie avec le printemps dernier est
intéressante je trouve parce qu' une des
raisons pour lesquelles il y avait une
grande adhésion populaire et compris des
milieux d'affaires c'était quand on
avait une espèce d'échéancier on se
disait pour combattre la première
wingles il faut tout faire le nécessaire
maintenant pour espérer avoir un été
plus ou moins normal c'était ce que dit
monsieur vous donc on se dit on donne un
peu au printemps puis on va récolter les
fruits notre effort à l'été alors que là
on sait pas si c'est le défi 28 jours
ces défis 90 jours ci c'est le défi 2020
donc on voit ports vont à la difficulté
à voir la lumière au bout du tunnel et
les dommages économiques se sont
accumulées depuis le printemps dernier
hélas
les situations difficiles au printemps
dernier sont devenues critiques
aujourd'hui sur le plan économique donc
on le voit c'est vraiment beaucoup plus
difficile à faire appliquer à vendre il
ay le 10 puis je le parle plus beaux
mots justes mais il a dit la santé
d'abord puis si on contrôle pas la
pandémie tout le reste prend d'abord ça
veut dire que c'est d'abord protéger le
réseau de l'hospitalier réseau de la
santé c'est la santé publique d'abord
puis d autres considérations bombe par
les ordres d'un endroit qui pourrait
encore faire mal puis dieu sait que ça
fait mal dans l'est dans les foyers pour
personnes âgées dans les sièges à celle
des on va écouter un extrait de monsieur
dubé puis là le ton du tout on le sent
extrêmement préoccupé où on en est
aujourd'hui après 50 jours d'une
deuxième vague versus 50 jours d'une
première vague on n'est pas du tout dans
le même registre on parle de d'à peu
près 320 personnes contaminées dans nos
40 ch et celle des à la même date la 50e
journée
la première vague c'était plus de 2500
personnes qui étaient contaminés dans à
peu près une centaine de chf qu'on est
pas du tout dans le même registre on ne
réussit jusqu'à maintenant pour
parfaitement
né à contrôler l'épidémie dans les chcd
à l'exception de 4 ou 5 ch sld
me dit clairement qu'il fallait protéger
nous indigner ch et cd c'était carrément
sur mon monde
je dors très mal c'est ainsi je suis
préoccupé qu'il ya quelqu'un à ce moment
qu'ils responsable c'est moi
puis je peux vous dire que je vais
m'assurer qu'on vaut rester en contrôle
c'est pas facile mais je pense qu adapte
le plan fonctionne malgré une situation
difficile mais je suis responsable de se
défendre et on a donné les deux côtés de
la médaille d'abord il dit puis j'en ai
un tableau pop qui le montrent qu'on
n'est pas du tout dans la même situation
que la première vague huit fois moins de
cas donc actuellement au 50e jour de la
deuxième vague par rapport au 50e jours
la première vague c'est une chose mais
vous l'avez entendu après paul il est
préoccupé parce que ça augmente quand
même on envoie des équipes dans trois
sièges à celle d aujourd'hui pour
s'assurer de colmater dont on est
inquiet évidemment oui s'il dit qu'ils
dorment à lille le duo ci peut très bien
se réveiller en voyant histoire révélée
par mon journal ce matin épouvantable
qui est impardonnable où il ya des gens
qui ont été transférés en zone chaude à
cause d'un diagnostic et rené se le dit
comme gestionnaire il ya des limites à
ce qu'ils peuvent faire comme ministre
que ça veut prenez l'exemple des zones
chaudes et froides les déplacements
d'une zone à l'autre
monsieur dubé audi il y en aura plus de
mobilité du personnel
les gens vont rester assigné à la même
zone puis après on lui a dit que c'était
pas applicable parce qu'ils manquaient
déjà
donc il a ajouté une exception le dis si
on a le choix entre avoir personne pour
la donner les soins ou avoir une
personne qui se déplacent mais on va y
aller avec la mobilité donc on voit
qu'il est pris avec certains problèmes
qu'il précédait dans la santé
et on peut dire pour les préposés aux
bénéficiaires quand même à la décharge
du gouvernement ils ont quand même
réussi à en former une 8000 avec le
programme express
par contre pour les infirmières le
problème non seulement demain
mais ça grave à cause des départs à la
retraite anticipés d'infirmières qui
sont écoeurés de leurs conditions de
travail et ça met la pression sur le
gouvernement avec les négociations en
cours en ce moment avec les infirmières
exactement martin oui et on sortait
contre discours dans ce que dit le
gouvernement et la santé publique et on
l'a vu dans le point de presse cet après
midi et je trouve ça très intéressant
que vous ayez choisi cet extrait où le
ministre de la santé dit que huit fois
moins de cas au jour 50 de la première
vague et la deuxième vague une minute et
demie avant je pense qu'il dit ça le
docteur arruda expliqué aux journalistes
que la première vague la deuxième vague
et les peaux pareil la deuxième vague
elle a commencé la contamination
commencé chez les jeunes qui
tranquillement sournoisement ont
effectué les plus vieux et
tranquillement l'aco vide se retrouve
dans le cas de la deuxième vague dans
les chsct alors c'est tout à fait normal
que les ch et celle d aujourd 50 soit un
moyen fait qd et que dans la première
vague là la deuxième vague de qu'ovide
commence à frapper les ch et cdc plus
sauf qu'on devra entendre
et là on va pouvoir vérifier comment le
gouvernement est organisée pour faire
face à la deuxième vague en 6 h et celle
des on a appris aujourd'hui qu'ils
avaient des équipes d'urgence qui était
formée des hôpitaux qui devait se
déployer dans les chu celles dues aux
besoins c'est une bonne nouvelle parce
qu'en première vague les hôpitaux et les
clsc l'idée n'était pas arrimé le voyons
voir sylvain capable de les déployer
rapidement mais le discours n'est pas en
phase sur la question dès 6 h et celle
du fc brussels
c'est ça le test politique le test
politique qui s'en vient pour françois
legault avec les sièges celle des sa
marge d'erreur vis-à-vis des sièges cd
est très faible parce que dans la
première vague
on a tous été renversés troublé par ce
qui s'est passé dans les sièges cd mais
c'était une nouvelle
une attaque nouvelle à laquelle personne
n'était vraiment préparé leur principe
il est supposé préparer avant les
équipements nécessaires avant le
personnel nécessaire ou à peu près le
personnel nécessaire avoir le contrôle
des infections avoir déterminé les zones
chaudes les zones froides et chaque jour
on apprend certains détails des choses
qui ne se font pas bien et en parallèle
comme on l'a dit ils essaient de
négocier avec des syndicats qui font des
manifestations en mettant des effigies
de 125 personnes qui est le nombre de
personnes on doit s'occuper une
infirmière et une infirmière auxiliaire
chaque nuit dans les sièges dans
certains chu fédération c'est à dire sur
les fameux ratio way we pole parce que
là dessus tout le monde souhaite de
meilleurs ratios mais ça coûte de
l'argent puis ça prend plus de monde
c'est un peu la question de l'oeuf ou la
poule
parce que si on adopte des ratios de
demain mais il n'y a pas assez
d'infirmières pour les respecter donc on
forcerait les établissements à adopter
quelque chose d'inédit câble par contre
on prédire inversement que si les
infirmières n'applique haut sur les
postes à temps plein c'est parce que ça
les intéresse pas parce qu'elles savent
qu'elles vont être sûrement que savait
des conditions de travail
invivable donc est-ce que si on ouvre
les portes demain matin honda avec des
ratios on va être surpris puis vont se
remplir
peut-être mais tous en ce moment ça fait
l'objet de la négociation
puis on sait you will you le
gouvernement qui négocie avec les
syndicats qui représentent les
intérieurs mais il ya aussi en parallèle
les gestionnaires d'hôpitaux qui eux ont
leurs caprices des gestionnaires
d'établissements les antilles aime bien
ça avoir une mobilité de main d'oeuvre
c'est plus facile pour eux
pour l'heure leur mode de gestion piste
casting va falloir régler vite martin
lorsque la négo le ya une pression
énorme ne faudrait normalement que ça
serait qu'on annonce de bonnes nouvelles
que affirmé en soit heureuse quand qu'on
fasse face à cette crise
surtout que les infirmières ils ont un
fort taux
de sympathie elles sont très appréciés
surtout en temps de pandémie
bon il est préposé aux bénéficiaires ont
eu quand même de certains privilèges je
pense que les infirmières veulent ou
s'ils pensent que c'est leur tour et que
c'est le temps de régler plusieurs
choses pour elle bon la surcharge de
travail sonia lebel a dit aujourd'hui
que c'était ça la priorité qu'elle sent
très ces efforts là dessus mais en même
temps elle a dit gros défi ça prend du
monde pour travailler de nuit et sapins
du monde pour travailler la semaine
aussi bien sûr sonia lebel c'est son
gros gros gros défi on va suivre ça
t'intéresse à merci à vous trois merci à
vous trois votre voix merci
[Musique]